hey guys so I haven't posted a little
well and I thought it'd be worth doing a
video explaining what's going to happen
to this channel in the future so most of
my videos on this channel have been
about access to Oxbridge and
specifically it's been about giving you
an idea of what it's like to be an
undergraduate at the University of
Oxford now I've done my final exams and
I'm soon to graduate I can't really do
that anymore I'm not an undergrad you
anymore
and that's such this channel in the
future is going to move away from doing
that kind of access material because
there's a more appropriate place about
to be hosted having said that in the
next couple of weeks I'm gonna load in a
series of videos of mine college access
traps answering questions that you guys
have submitted so that's gonna be hosted
not just on this channel but also on my
colleges issue channel SPC Oxford my
college being st. Peter's uploads gonna
be alternating between the channels so
if you want to make sure that you see
all the videos then i highly recommend
you subscribe to your SPC Oxford as well
there's gonna be links in of each video
to the next part
but that channels are gonna be getting a
lot of content in the future also if the
reason that you subscribed was because
of my series of vlogging videos and if
you haven't watched them I've been doing
a video blog every week in term time for
the past year talking about what it's
like to be an Oxford student there's a
link to a playlist of all the videos in
the description now because I not know
undergraduate anymore like I said I
can't really do that anymore but there's
a new project which is coming up very
soon which I'm involved with that I'm
probably putting up a video about in a
couple of weeks time that style of
vlogging project is gonna return and
it's gonna be a lot bigger now you might
very well ask that because this channel
was essentially founded on doing Oxford
access stuff what's gonna happen in the
future of the new material now I have
some ideas of what I'd like to do I've
got a series of videos plan that I'm
gonna be making in the next couple of
weeks and months they'll be uploaded to
this channel but I'm completely open to
suggestions about videos that you'd like
to see I'm a physicist by training and I
have an interest just very broadly in
science and mathematics and I'm really
interested to see what you guys would
like to see in YouTube videos in terms
of where I'm aiming to go with the
content somewhere between if you know
the channels minutephysics and scishow
talking about contents concepts in a
little bit more depth that you might see
otherwise and ideally forming
between high school physics like a level
science generally on university level so
you kind of get a taster of what a
subject might be like at university so
if you have a particular topic or
subject that you'd like to see a video
of then leave a comment below and I will
see what works in case you're wondering
about the t-shirt by the way I'm not
communist I just really like Rakhi for
in other news I am also finally on
Twitter at Simon Oxford if you want to
follow me in addition to having a
Facebook page which you can follow again
to repeat what I said before I don't
accept friend requests of people I
definitely personally be you're very
welcome to follow me in my mundane life
and lastly at the end of this month I am
taking part in a charity event called
trail Walker this is where you have 30
hours to 100 kilometers across the South
Downs I'm doing this as part of a team
that is raising money for our
international after the Gurkha Welfare
Trust and frankly it's gonna hurt a lot
so if you would like to support me or in
fact if you've found the videos I've
been making over the past couple it is
useful to you I would really really
appreciate donation there's a Just
Giving page which I'll put on the screen
and in the description I you completely
understand if you don't want to donate
but the link is there if you would like
to and thank you in advance because like
I say this is gonna really really hurt
more access stuff coming this channel in
the near future but after that I've been
moving more into science tech stuff but
not to worry because Oxford access with
vlogs are going to be taking place on a
different You Tube channel in the next
academic year so keep your eyes peeled
for an announcement on that and I will
see you well then I guess